evan
evan you're next
i love it i love it i love it
more dancing guys
all right all right all right all right
all right thank you thank you i'm
crashing a little bit it's 4 30 in the
morning my time right now
but i got my coffee and my water and i'm
really excited to be here with you guys
for this one
the session today is socializing
how do you add more zing to your social
campaigns and i thought the best thing
that i could do
for you today is help you create the
most
powerful tweet you've ever written in
your life so in the next 15 minutes in
this room you guys are all whoever has
twitter
you're all going to write the most
powerful tweet you've ever written
in your life you excited
all right i'm going to show you to do it
you guys have seen this slide your stuff
right now is boring
right you're putting people to sleep
you're not even excited about your stuff
you're not proud of it you wouldn't
retweet it if it was if you weren't
forced to do it because it was your
company stuff
you got to create something you're proud
of you have to create a movement you
have to create something that
will get people excited they have to
believe in what you're doing you have to
make them feel something
and once you do that then they're going
to be willing to buy your products or
services
so i want you all to take out your
phones take out your laptops
log into twitter this is an important
exercise
i want you to close your eyes close your
eyes don't fall asleep on me okay
if i do it i might fall asleep don't
fall asleep but close your eyes and
this is guys this is really important
what i want you to do right now
is think about a problem you had in your
past think about who you were the person
you were two years ago three years ago
five years
ago think about the place that you are
in
and i want you to right now go back and
imagine you could give
the younger you some advice you're
giving yourself
advice the younger you who is facing a
problem
and i want you to use this hashtag
msmwzing
and i want to put it up when i want to
see it
for me i might think about my business
when i was making my 300 bucks a month
and
barely survived and thinking about
quitting i might tweet something like
don't give up you're gonna make it
believe i want you to think about the
advice that you would give to yourself
and i want you to put it on the screen
right now this is important guys i want
you to really think about it and put it
on the screen
what do we got here take the scholarship
ahmad
live life enjoy the little things more
don't apply for a credit card
b you will never change believe in
yourself and soldier on
keep them coming good bonus points if
you guys can include
the one word that we came up with this
morning you can put that in there too as
a hashtag
you have to choose friends or family you
should choose family
survive the leap of faith you're just
about to find something that you will
love to do
is it great let go like it's going too
fast i can't even keep up let go of the
past be merry again always think twice a
small move big change this is great
you are injecting emotion into your
tweets maybe for the first time ever
do what you want to do embrace life i
want to do one more
i'm upset that okay i know we just came
from a political discussion
let's try to avoid politics on this one
i want you to write i'm upset that and
fill in the blank
same hashtag msmw zing if it were me
i might write something like i'm upset
that
people listen to other people's opinions
instead of believing in themselves
i would i wanted to do this with you
guys but i left my phone in the taxi
yesterday coming back from kl
yeah so i have no phone but you guys are
doing it
i'm upset that what are you guys upset
about i'm upset that some people are too
selfish for their own good
and most of the people lack faith in
themselves this is great
what else i said i have a credit card
debt you guys need your credit cards i'm
upset that people give up on their
dreams too quickly
i'm upset that the food is bland i'm
upset that i didn't try harder
oh it's already gone i'm upset that i'm
fat
that's good listen you need to
inject emotion and passion into
everything that you're doing on social
media
okay i love it keep these keep these
coming we set
we set a trending record i think last
time with our one word and it's awesome
to see these all coming in now there's
not even like a second delay it's now
now now it's great
so the question becomes evan this is
great
so i'm upset that i'm fat what the heck
does that have to do with business
right i work at a company i'm managing a
social media campaign what does this
have to do with business
it has everything to do with business
because until people feel your message
until people
get some excitement from until you make
them feel something good or bad
they're never going to buy from you
they're never going to want to interact
with you they're going to ignore you
you have to learn to inject passion and
emotion
into your tweets and this shouldn't be
hard just think about who you are
and that one word that you stand for
everything you create should make you
feel something
if you're putting out a facebook post an
instagram picture a twitter
post if it doesn't make you feel
something
if it doesn't get your heart beating
don't post it
that's the test i'm going to uh
maybe offend some people with my next
comment we don't have a lot of speakers
here so that's good
i'm not a big believer in making
quantitative decisions
and that applies to social media
campaigns i'm not the guy who's going to
look at all the market research
and say here's what people are talking
about so here's what we're going to
tweet about
the problem with making quantitative
only decisions
is that there's no passion in it there's
no emotion to it
you don't feel excited by it it's like
people who start a business just trying
to make money
if you are trying to start a business
just trying to make money you're never
gonna make it
money is important i'm not saying you
start a business or in your company now
you ignore the quantitative stuff but
it's not the reason
to do something one of my favorite
entrepreneurs is steve jobs
you guys like steve jobs
no come on guys steve jobs all right
good
hands up i love steve jobs okay now
steve jobs the story this guy was a
multi-millionaire in his early twenties
multi-millionaire in his early twenties
he had enough money to live the rest of
his life and happiness
and yet he worked until the day he died
making amazing products for apple
why did he do it it wasn't for the money
and people told him he was crazy
people told him at the beginning of
apple nobody needs a personal computer
what are you stupid nobody needs a
personal computer
when he launched the ipad when he
launched the ipod people thought he was
crazy people thought
this will never this will never sell
because there's no data to prove it
there's no quantitative data why did he
do it
he did it because he felt like this was
needed he did it
to do it that's why he did he did it
because it was important because he
wanted to change the world
and for steve jobs the number one
criteria was never the money
it was never the quantitative stuff
and yet he built apple to become the
number one most
valuable company in the world by market
cap
that's the power when you inject your
own passion
into your business so i'm not saying
completely ignore the quantitative stuff
but you don't make decisions in this
context
social media campaigns only on a
quantitative stuff
you have to get excited and feel it in
your heart
of every single post that you're putting
on your social media campaign
and you'll post stuff on there even
ignoring the quantitative stuff because
it's the right thing to do
and if you do that then you'll gain a
loyal following
and people will can't wait to see your
next tweet
and then they're going to buy from you
and tell everybody about you
that's my view we've gone through these
slides okay right you have one word
equality
freedom heart innovation entertain
believe
i wanted to share this one slide these
are from my morning session
and one person wrote nice t-shirt can i
have one too
i'm working on it right now these are
just for me a line is coming
and that was super inspiring now i
believe so
the importance of having the one word
and then applying it to your social
media campaign
it does two things one it makes your
decision making process
easier so we had a young woman stand up
and say her one word is empathy
now everything that she writes about is
going to be about empathy
if she ends up hiring a graphic designer
it has to be somebody who believes in
empathy
it makes the decision making so much
easier
but the other thing it does is
it helps people talk about you if you
give people one word to help you spread
the message they're gonna remember it
and they're gonna do it
there's a guy who came up to me after my
first session said i'm in the travel
agency business
and uh wow that's like that's a brutal
business right everybody's selling the
exact same stuff there's no difference
in the product
and he said his one word is experience
he likes to give people an experience
when they go traveling
he wants them to have an experience now
this is something i can relate to i hate
going on beachy vacations
you know i come here i want to go to the
caves i want to do the rving i want to i
want to have an experience
and right away he's now separated
himself from every other travel agent
and it's easy for me to talk about him
here it's easy for me to tell my friends
about him because he's given me the tool
to do it
so when you find your one word it makes
it easier to make decisions it makes it
easier for you to plan your social media
campaigns
but it also makes it easier for people
to spread your message
people are hashtagging believe all over
the place
i make it easy for them and you need to
do the same thing with your business
so what do you stand for we went through
that exercise this morning
if you know you haven't figured that out
it's okay you guys did a great job
finding your one word i didn't get to it
that quickly
it took me a couple weeks before i got
to believe so you guys are
rocking it but if you're not comfortable
with your word
take the time and really figure it out
because it's going to be everything for
you and your business
and in my view that's how you add zing
through social media campaigns
uh now quickly again on thursday for
those of you who are coming i'm going to
go through this whole thing in an hour
we have a lot more time
and one last quick announcement about
the salsa it's become this thing now
dj selva is he here dj selva in the
house
way at the back corner so he has hooked
it up that we're going to go
to havana kl tonight
and i'm going to be djing for a set
so if you like salsa or if you just want
to have a good time and here's some
music come on
out it starts at nine o'clock there's a
lesson it goes on i'm gonna be there
hope to meet you guys and one last thing
for you guys we
as the speakers come here the best part
is meeting you
right like i come here and talk as much
as i want but i love talking to you guys
and i've had some great conversations
don't be afraid
to come up and find me afterwards to
talk to me don't be afraid to find any
of these speakers
because that's that's the most rewarding
part for us you have a question
you guys have paid good money to be here
you have a question what i answered come
and talk to us we love but you're not
imposing on us
and believe
i know the time now is 6 p.m you guys
are waiting till
now can you spare a few more minutes can
you maximize your time to ask
the panel any question this is not to
actually ask a question it's to pick a
fight with stevens
so that i can break his leg and he can't
go to salsa
i'm just i'm just jealous about his
height youth
and uh all the thing all people killing
me man no never mind so i i
heard something and that's like
something um
that analytics or data or
quantitative information is not
important feeling is
my question is where is the
contradiction right
um saying that feeling can make your
social presence great
is like even if i have a bad product and
if i really don't believe in my product
i can go in social media and create a
great magic it's not possible that's
given that you
have a great product to start with you
are passionate about your business and
you
are really a true believer of what
you're doing not to just to make money
right that's given but then you have to
take the qualitative staff
and quantitative all the information and
analysis to go
to do the right thing isn't it true for
me it's a difference between
thinking with your head and acting with
your heart
right and your brain is limited into a
world that exists
world that exists right now where your
heart
can create any world that you want okay
and let me tell you through a story
when i was growing up in high school i
never thought i was going to be an
entrepreneur
i thought i was going to be a vp at a
bank i look at my high school yearbook
that's what it says vp at a bank
okay i didn't have family of
entrepreneurs i didn't know what i was
going to do
when i got to university i hooked up
with a software company i became an
owner
and in my final year i got job
opportunities
with mckinsey consulting and merrill
lynch
which only a few years prior would have
been a dream scenario
i couldn't imagine working for a better
company
they were offering me 80 to 100 000
starting salary they flew me out to new
york put me up in the waldorf astoria
to try to get me to join the company and
i'm balancing two things
80 to thousand dollars a year
three hundred dollars a month with my
company
what does the brain say to do what is
the quantitative data i say to do
it's easy go for the job that's where
the money is
but it didn't feel right so you have to
listen to your heart
that's my view you have to listen to
your heart you have to be passionate
about it
my friends thought i was crazy they
weren't getting those job opportunities
they said evan what are you what is this
company and
years later like 10 years later my
friends now coming back to me
and they're saying evan i i took that
job in investment banking
and i hate my life i know i want to
start my own business
how do i do it and i'm so glad that i
didn't make that decision the smart
thing to do right
the quantitative logical money-making
thing to do
to go get the job i had no logical
reason
no logical reason to stick with this 300
a month company
but i did does that answer your question
no actually not uh sorry
so um what i meant that obviously you
have to be
passionate to start with right so you
have to be like i took up a
entrepreneurial life off of my own so
that's the given right then after that
when you're taking decision day by day
every time if your heart says do that
and go this side and every time the
heart says go
to the left and you go that side and you
have no
actual evidence to support your decision
you'll be running around
in everywhere not reaching anywhere
right so you have to
have no disagree okay disagree
quite often the analytical decision
is the wrong way to go because you're
restricting yourself
of a world that currently exists
where you can create any reality you
want yeah you have to believe in what
you're doing
that's the whole point of my first
presentation you pick your one word
right if you guys don't
believe in what you're doing there is no
passion so yeah you have to pick your
one word you have to start
a career or business around that
but i believe your decision should be
based on
what gets you excited you're creating a
social media campaign
i would challenge you guys like why put
that video up that believe video
150 000 views in one month
not made on any quantitative decisions i
made it because
i wanted to make it it needed to be made
and i'm
proud of what we made and i would
challenge you guys
with no advertising to see what videos
you've made based on quantitative
decisions that have gone that well
what you just stated as a proof of
success
you said this is watched this many times
you just give a quantitative information
to support the theory that quantitative
disinformation doesn't matter
i don't say it doesn't matter no i mean
it's not that it doesn't matter but
it's not the main reason no this is a
big difference it's not the main reason
for doing
anything right you can still look at it
steve jobs didn't say i'm going to lose
all my money i'm going to just throw it
all in r d he still had to make money
but it was never the main reason for
doing anything okay
i think we take this offline yeah sure
we have time for one or two more
questions
does anybody want to go next